let's go again full name job title all
that stuff my name is Zack McLeod
Pinsent I twenty five years old and I
don't own aware any modern clothing and
whom I go oh that's strange
it is strange if I enjoy what I'm doing
them why change
I've never felt more happy with just
wearing what I'm wearing as a form of
self-expression you know it's never been
a tension thing anyway although here I
am on the BBC I think it's always that
really important thing to just believe
in yourself which sounds like a
ridiculous thing and it's said too much
but it's worth it sometimes
I've never had the wish to dress
normally I did that for so many years
and I hated it so what's the point of
returning once evolved
I remember ceremoniously burning my last
pair of jeans at the age of 14 maybe
somewhere in the back of a drawer that
I'm not using is probably a pair of
moccasins Betances underwear wearing
what I wear it makes you feel 10 feet
high
you know it's spectacular it's a huge
confidence builder you fight so hard
generally externally because you're
always ready for it it's whether
everyone else is once you get past that
point and you can finally do it you'd
never dream of going back your cage you
might get the odd comment from a drug
person at 3:00 in the morning but that's
the drunk person at 3:00 in the morning
but now I think generally people are
really really appreciative and
interested and they might think it's a
bit odd but so what
I run a business
Lord knows how where I make men and
women's of spoke clothing from the 1660s
to the 1920s specializing in the
Georgian and Regency period
one of my New York clients were just
like a 18th century banyan to wear
around his home why not
men's fashion there isn't enough
flamboyant sand color clothes our social
history so what I get from it is that
bringing it alive and making people
really happy seeing the joy in someone's
face when they've got something which is
made for them for maybe the first time
in their life and it fits them and
they're happy in it
there's no better feeling
you